NIGHT IN COLORADO. ZONE.
SCORE.
LONG SHOT.ST
HE SCORES.
THE WINNIPEG  LOWEST SCORING
GROUP
NOW YOU HAVE NEW THE FAR
SIDE.
HE WILL BE ABLE TO CLEAR.
THE T.
LOWRY HAS AN OPPORTUNITY.
HE WILL MOVE IT IN AND SHOO
AGAIN, NOT MUCH.
YOU KNOW YOU KIND OF WORRY ABOUT
IT. SMITH.
CONVERTED
>> Marc: SHOT, BLOCKED AWAY. AL.
THE FACE-OFF.
YOU SAW HOW LANDESKOG, HOW
DETERMININ
NOW ONE.
BURAKOVSKY.
ANDRE BURAKOVSKY.
FLY AHEAD.
MACKINNON SHOOTS AND
YOU HAVE GIVEN HIM TOO MUCH
ONE.
FOR BLOCKED AWAYAY
SCORE.
DEFLECTED BY GABE LANDESKOG.
NICHUSHKIN TO THE FRONT OF TH E.
LOOK AT HIM COME DOWN.
HE KEEPS TH THE ENTIRE
FAMILY.
NEWH THE AVS CATCH HIM. DO
CARE.AHEAD
KILLING.
THEY
AHEAD TO BURAKOVSKY.
CENTERING PASS. GOAL OF THE  TO.
HE COULD HAVELOOK AT THAT?